[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour un nouveau
numéro de mode d'emploi votre magazine
consacré à l'emploi et à la formation
professionnelle
focus ce mois ci sur les jobs d'été tout
de suite le sommaire dernière ligne
droite pour trouver un job d'été
restauration commerce tourisme des
secteurs qui embauchent
et si vous êtes mineur nous avons aussi
des solutions pour vous y des conseils
et astuces pour décrocher un job d'été
nous recevons l'europe ce cousin
directrice dit les d'information
jeunesse
ils sont les héros du film nos jours
heureux les animateurs de colonies de
vacances ou d'accueil de loisirs un
emploi saisonnier classique à condition
d'avoir le bafa et la ville de plaisir
en force ces équipes d'animation
jeunesse avec 20 postes à pourvoir
enfin l' agence de services à domicile
au de recherche 175 collaborateurs dans
les yvelines embauchés directement en
cdi un job dating est prévue le 6 juin
les détails
à la fin de cette émission et nous
accueillons tout de suite laurence
cousin bonjour bonjour directrice de
yvelines à l'information jeunesse on va
parler avec vous du dispositif yvelines
étudiants seniors et d autres
possibilités pour les jeunes pour
trouver un job d'été un peu la dernière
minute en tout à fait alors
effectivement vous parlez du dispositif
qu'on dit yes du conseil départemental
c'est ça ou c'est autre chose en fait on
s'adapte à la demande du jeune à son
profil et surtout que mois de mai donc
dernière minute un peu c'est voilà
exactement a effectivement puisque le
service de nos jobs d'été dating qu'on
organise tous les ans ont déjà eu lieu
on verra justement on va en parler on va
voir tirer le bilan aussi de ces jobs
dating mais avant direction plaisir la
commune recherche actuellement une
vingtaine d'animateurs pour ses centres
d'accueil de loisirs pour les vacances
d'été
alors quelles sont les missions et les
caractéristiques d'un animal secteur
jeunesse
nous sommes allés à leur rencontre un
mercredi matin direction l'accueil de
loisirs mixte maternelles et
élémentaires des loupiots
ambiance kuduro ce matin là au centre
d'accueil loisirs les loupiots de
plaisir comme chaque mercredi cette
structure de la commune accueille près
une quarantaine d'enfants âgés de 3 à 10
ans encadrés par des animateurs de la
ville à 2 3 4 4 peut mieux faire
après ce moment libre dans la cour place
aux activités du matin thibault a
préparé quatre jeux de réflexion et
d'attention j'ai des valeurs et le mont
but ça va être des données les vannes
ces valeurs aux enfants par le biais
d'activités par le biais de petits jeux
de de consignes de règles c'est ce qui
compte en fait c'est d'être à l'écouté
des enfants de pouvoir toujours raide si
la surveillance mais de faire des champs
montants de son côté bénédicte est parti
avec quelques jeunes au gymnase léo
lagrange un tournoi de football inter
centres d'accueil de loisirs est
organisée durant la matinée depuis 2007
elle exerce le métier d'animatrice à
plaisir après un bep sanitaire et social
et son brevet d'aptitude aux fonctions
d'animateur quand les enfants ils
viennent nous voir et nous disent oui
c'était bien c'était génial
on en veut encore
voilà c'est ça en fait il fait plaisir
de voir les enfants contents et heureux
même c'est la base du métier durant
l'été la commune ouvre quatre accueils
de loisirs les enfants sont accueillis
de 7h30 à 18h 45 du lundi au vendredi
les animateurs travaillent entre 47 et
48 heures par semaine pour des
indemnités moyenne de 2000 euros la
ville recherche actuellement des
collaborateurs pour compléter ses
équipes tout ce qu'on attend c'est
surtout du dynamisme du peps une bonne
logique
à défaut de beaucoup d'expérience on
leur demande d'avoir une certaine
logique
une organisation un peu de rigueur on a
on des étudiants qui sont en école d'art
qui vont pouvoir ouvrir un peu les
activités sur tout ce qui est artistique
c'est là que pour nous c'est vraiment un
plus
c'est c'est un bon apprentissage que
d'être déjà animateur parce que voilà ça
permet aux plus jeunes parfois de
trouver c'est justement ce petit job
d'été et puis et puis il faut savoir que
plus tard sur un cv c'est une bonne
expérience
prochaines sessions de recrutement
organisée à la maison de l'emploi de
plaisir mercredi 29 mai de 12h à 17h30
alors pour résumer si vous souhaitez
candidater à ces postes vous devez être
titulaire du bafa ou vous pouvez
profiter de cet été pour effectuer votre
stage pratique dans un centre d'accueil
de loisirs donc à plaisir dans ce cas le
dynamisme la créativité dans le choix
des activités sont appréciés il faut
compter entre 47 et 48 heures de travail
par semaine
spécifiquement aux vacances d'été pour
des indemnités d'environ 2000 euros net
par mois alors n'hésitez pas aussi à
vous renseigner auprès de vos communes
parce que les communes recherche
actuellement des animateurs pour leurs
centres d'accueil de loisirs pour la
période estivale
laurence prison je me tourne vers vous
on vient de voir le sujet sur le secteur
de l'animation c'est une réelle
opportunité pour décrocher un job d'été
pour un jeune homme est complètement et
puis c'est vrai que le fait pouvoir
passer le bafa à partir de 17 ans il
faut avoir 17 ans révolus premier jour
du stage
ça peut être une opportunité pour des
jeunes qui sont mineurs et qui ont
quelques difficultés à trouver un job
d'été de se lancer dans une formation et
donc c'est une vraie valeur ajoutée pour
après être animateur
or comme je dis je le disais par mois au
début de cette émission le mois de mai
c'est un peu tard finalement quelles
sont les solutions pour un jeune
actuellement pour trouver un job d'été
alors bon déjà faut qu'ils réfléchissent
avant avant même de s'engager dans la
recherche faut déjà qu'ils se disent
combien de temps je suis disponible
donc c'est un mois minimum pour un job
d'été
au niveau qui sont mobiles aussi
géographiquement est ce qu ils peuvent
travailler en horaires décalés est-ce
qu'ils ont le permis de conduire en
train d'avoir un peu toutes les
opportunités qui peuvent avoir
et puis à cette période assez tardive
effectivement ça peut être des
désistements donc que ce soit pour les
animateurs on l'a vu à l'instant pour
compléter une équipe dans l'hôtellerie
restauration dans différents secteurs
d'activité pourquoi pas aussi voir aussi
au niveau des agences d'intérim s'il ya
des missions ponctuellement qui peuvent
qui peuvent faire pendant l'été ça c'est
des pistes qui peuvent qui peuvent
utiliser ensuite son papa aussi des
candidatures spontanées mais
effectivement je n'ai pas les
commerçants du quartier par exemple ou
tout simplement de demander s'il ya des
opportunités de d'emplois saisonniers
chez eux
on voit actuellement à l'image des
images 2d job dating que vous avez
organisé alors là c'est celui de bois
d'arcy celle d'une cession que vous
organisez depuis le mois de mars qui
s'est terminé fin avril-début mai là où
on met fin à son pool et ving derniers
mois dernier un forum jobs d'été a
semblé l'on vous fait de ce type de
cession est ce que vous avez beaucoup de
jeunes lors de tous les ans ça
fonctionne très très bien parce que
c'est une vraie demande des jeunes que
de pouvoir travailler pendant l'été donc
on a eu à peu près à chaque fois que tu
200 jeunes qui sont venus sur chaque
session entre 15 et 25 recruteurs sur
place parce que l'idée est intéressante
c'est qu'ils puissent déposer leur cv et
rencontrer les recruteurs sur sur place
parce qu'autrement ils peuvent venir de
notre réseau toute l'année et avoir des
informations pratiques
voilà là il y avait des offres un
constat coire nous avons pu faire un
notamment sur le job dating de bois
d'arcy nous avons rencontré plusieurs
mineurs je rappelle un l'âge légal pour
commencer à travailler ses 16 ans oui
mais entre 16 et 18 ans mais il y avait
beaucoup de jeunes qui venaient chercher
un travail qui a laissé à jeu
quelle solution pour eux finalement
parce que des employeurs de ces
difficiles pour mot celle ne recrute pas
formés illégalement effectivement c'est
possible pour eux nous on veut pas leur
fermer la porte parce qu'on invite aussi
des partenaires pour justement les
préparer à la éventuellement les années
précédentes prochaine à à se positionner
donc ils sont pas préparés au cv sont
pas forcément préparés à l'entretien de
motivation
donc ça on a des professionnels qui sont
là aussi pour pour donner des conseils
ils peuvent effectivement être
quelquefois déçu de pas trouvé sur les
25 on avait à bois d'arcy recruteurs y
en a trois ou quatre qui prenaient des
mineurs concrètement donc nous on veut
pas leur fermer la porte
on les accompagne on essaie de valoriser
leur cv aussi avec eux mais on leur dit
voilà déjà soyez disponible un mois un
mois et demi et puis fait aussi appel
aux réseaux de vos parents au réseau
professeur voilà donc des proches
parce quand ils vous connaissent un
voilà donc pour faut jouer notre carte
les portes sont pas fermées encore une
fois mais c'est quand même beaucoup plus
compliqué que pour les majeurs
effectivement autre solution proposée
par le conseil départemental des
yvelines cette fois ci depuis 2004 c'est
le dispositif yvelines étudiant senior
us
le principe les étudiants recrutés
rendre visite à des personnes âgées pour
s'occuper d'eux ces 145 jeunes recrues
n'est recruter chaque année c'est
quelque chose qui fonctionne à ça
fonctionne très bien tous les ans alors
après il faut effectivement avoir le
profil comme vous l'avez dit faut être
étudiant il faut avoir 20 ans minima
parce que c'est quand même une
responsabilité vous voilà il faur le
permis de conduire depuis plus d'un an
puisque vous allez dans les maisons de
retraite du département donc il faut
être mobile et avoir le permis de
conduire voilà si vous avez le profil et
que vous êtes et l'egypte vous postulez
directement sur le site du conseil
départemental et vous pouvez
éventuellement effectivement travaillé
auprès de personnes âgées
alors on a vu le site internet sa fiche
bien de votre structure en yvelines
information jeunesse vous allez aussi le
fascicule que les jeunes peuvent
effectivement consulter télécharger sur
notre site ou à voir
en version papier trouve un job qui leur
donne quinze pistes autant sur la
réglementation que des sites internet
pour trouver des jobs des emplois
saisonniers dans différents secteurs
d'activité laurence vous remercie d'être
venu sur notre plateau et si vous
souhaitez obtenir des conseils dans
votre recherche pour la rédaction de
votre cv de votre lettre de motivation
ou pour vous préparer un entretien le
pôle jeunesse de montigny le bretonneux
c'est vos voisins d'ailleurs organise
des ateliers pour vous accompagner
nous avons rencontré stéphanie gareau
directrice du pôle jeunesse de montigny
le bretonneux sur des images de jules
grevy leur montage de romain russe finit
[Musique]
en fonction de l'âge des jeunes
il ya différentes activités possibles
pour un job d'été pour les mineurs çà se
cantonne à deux trois domaines maximum
parce que on peut travailler à partir de
16 ans mais c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué après pour les majeurs c'est
tout type de domaine
[Musique]
on va repartir de leur cv 6 en 1 qui est
plutôt scolaire essayer de mettre en
avant certaines choses qui peuvent être
intéressantes par exemple dans
l'animation tout ce qui est en rapport
avec garde d'enfants baby sitting et
dans le commerce 6 en fait un stage de
découverte en troisième les expériences
extra scolaires ou extra est étudiante
comme le sport les activités
associatives sont des atouts aussi qu'on
peut mettre en avant dans sa candidature
[Musique]
on n'a pas toujours d'entretien embauche
pour un job d'été mais c'est bien de s'y
préparer surtout quand on n'a pas
l'habitude d'être face à un recruteur
pendant un entretien le les arguments
qu'on apporte sont importants mais aussi
la façon de s'exprimer le langage non
verbal sont aussi des points qu'ils sont
à travailler à prendre en considération
la personnalité être naturel détendu et
avoir un petit peu de répartie ça se
travaille
même si on est timide ça peut se
préparer
175 contrat à durée indéterminée à
pourvoir dans les yvelines l'entreprise
o2 spécialisé dans le service à domicile
organise un job dating le 6 juin 2010 9
directement dans ses agences
vous pouvez vous rendre notamment à
montigny le bretonneux et à plaisir aux
adresses qui s'affiche à l'écran 45
postes au total à saisir sur saint
quentin en yvelines mais vous pouvez
aussi vous rendre dans les agences de
versailles saint-germain-en-laye
rambouillet poissy ou mantes la ville
plusieurs activités proposées comme
assistant ménagers garde d'enfants ou
auxiliaire de vie
avant de refermer cette édition je
rappelle aux entreprises et aux
demandeurs d'emploi du territoire que
vous pouvez vous rendre sur le site sky
en pot à point fr pour effectuer vos
démarches
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve le mois
prochain pour un nouveau numéro à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]